the peak last winter is shown in the
green shaded section when vaccination
rates were low and cases
hospitalizations and deaths were high
the peak during the summer months was
when the delta variant was dominant is
in yellow shaded area when nearly 50
percent of the country had been
vaccinated with a primary series
and the third shaded section in orange
represents the past month when cases
dramatically increased due to the
omicron variant
right now nearly 64 percent of the
country has received a primary series
and about 50 percent of eligible people
over 18 are boosted
when you look at the delta period and
last winter as cases increase
hospitalizations and deaths increased in
a similar pattern
strikingly when we compare the past
month when omicron was the predominant
variant we see a clear separation
between cases
hospital admissions and deaths
and while cases have dramatically
increased and are five times higher than
they were during the delta wave
hospitalizations have not increased at
the same rate and deaths remain low in
comparison to the case counts
when looking across these three periods
though of high transmission in the
pandemic you can see that while the
number of hospitalizations is higher now
than we have ever previously seen
the ratio of hospitalizations to cases
remains lower than prior peaks
when we look at other disease severity
indicators measured among people who are
hospitalized with coven 19 such as
hospital length of stay icu admissions
and deaths these indicators are lower
with omicron than during previous
periods of high transmission
and this is likely attributable to two
key factors
first many people in our country have
some level of immunity from vaccination
and boosters or from previous infection
and second it's likely that omicron is
less severe than prior variants
although it's encouraging that omicron
appears to be causing less severe
disease it's important to remember that
we are still facing a high overall
burden of disease
hospitalizations have rapidly increased
in a short amount of time putting a
strain on many local health systems
importantly milder does not mean mild
and we cannot look past the strain on
our health systems and substantial
number of deaths nearly 2 200 a day
as a result of the extremely
transmissible omicron variant
please remember the importance of our
prevention measures including
vaccination and boosters
last week i highlighted three
publications that described the
effectiveness of booster doses in
protecting against the omicron variant
it is of critical importance that the
people remain that people remain up to
date on cdc's
covet 19 recommendation
it's vital that we all remain vigilant
in the face of this virus
i know many people are tired but many of
our hospitals are still struggling
beyond capacity
it's been a long two years however
please now do your part to lean into
this current moment now is the time to
do what we know works wear a mask get
vaccinated and get boosted thank you and
i'll turn it over to dr fauci
thank you very much dr bolinsky i'd like
to spend the next few minutes talking
about our plans for the future and our
current activities
on the development of a universal
coronavirus vaccine first slide please
a little bit over a month ago my nih
colleagues and i wrote a perspective in
the new england journal of medicine
talking about the urgent need of a
universal coronavirus vaccine
the reason we did this perspective was
to bring to the attention of the public
next slide
the fact that in reality over the past
20 years since
2002
we've had three coronavirus major
disease outbreaks saws mares and cobot
19 which we are currently experiencing
however since september of 2020
there have been five saws kobe 2
variants of concern alpha beta gamma
delta and now the current omicron
and so obviously innovative approaches
are needed
to induce broad and durable protection
against coronaviruses that are known
and some that are even at this point
unknown hence
the terminology panned coronavirus
vaccine but i want to explain why this
is somewhat of a complicated issue next
slide
this is what we call a phylogenetic tree
of the coronaviruses if you look in the
center of the circle that's the original
source and like a tree it has many many
branches and as you can see there are
many different types of coronaviruses
those that have affected humans are in
red font
if you look at the alpha coronaviruses
the two there with yellow
were really part of the four
common cold coronaviruses that we each
get challenged and infected with usually
in the winter months
but if you look among the beta
coronaviruses you see the three
that have caused pandemic threats and
reality next slide
so let's put a
uh circle
on the size cov2 where we are
we've had now five different variants
alpha beta gamma delta and omicron that
have impacted us here in the united
states
also if you go to the next slide you see
that there's a good relationship next
slide please between the sars cov1 and
kovi ii they are both what we call
subecco viruses which are a subset of
the beta coronaviruses the reason i say
this
is that looking at the entirety
of the coronavirus
phylogenetic tree
it would be unreasonable to think we're
going to get a pan coronavirus for all
of them but we can focus in
on some of the subsets
particularly the sars kovi ii
and the entirety of the subekovirus
which includes sarsko v1 next slide
having said that what are we doing
the nih particularly niaid
has invested a little bit more than
three billion dollars overall
on coronavirus research since the
pandemic began
a subset of that
is coronavirus vaccine research thus far
about one and a half billion dollars
with investments in basic
and clinical biomedical research
particularly recent awards
of about 43 million dollars to four
academic institutions
to do specific research
to develop these types of vaccines which
i just mentioned
but already there have been results from
funding that has been gone on over the
past couple of years next slide
these are just a few
of the scientific reports of examples of
promising
candidates
that are at pre-clinical namely in a
mouse or another small animal
as well as non-human primates
as well as getting ready already in
phase one trials next slide
these are based on a concept of looking
at a vaccine construct
i had said in a previous white house
press briefing when i described the mrna
that one can look at it as a vaccine
platform
and a vaccine imaging the platform
currently now that we talk about a lot
is the mrna
or the ad vector whereas the vaccine
immunogen
is for example that spike protein in its
pre-fusion stabilized form that served
the basis for the mrna and other
vaccines so here's two examples of what
is going on now next slide
for example a number of groups have used
the nanoparticle approach which is the
platform
the immunogen of the different spike
protein fragments which when put in a
vaccine
would lead to a diverse antibody
response hence covering a broad array of
a particular virus
next slide another example is an
inactivated whole virus vaccine
where you have different versions of the
coronaviruses that are delivered by an
intranasal mix and this is important
because this will go a long way to
protecting against infection
and spread of infection i just give
those two examples because there are two
of many that are now currently being
produced next slide the final slide is
some key points
i don't want anyone to think that pan
coronavirus vaccines are literally
around the corner in a month or two it's
going to take years to develop in an
incremental fashion some of these are
already in phase one
clinical trials
don't forget however
that our current vaccine regimens
do provide strong protection
particularly when used with a booster
against severe coronavirus disease and
death
so do not wait to receive your primary
vaccine regimen and if you're a vaccine
please get your booster if you are
eligible
back to you jeff
thanks doctors with that let's open it
up for some questions kevin
thanks jeff uh first question let's go
to nate wexel at the hill
all right thanks for taking my question
uh wondering about tests uh
is there any effort underway at the
administration to get medicare to
uh cover some of these tests
reimbursement like private insurance is
doing right now
and thanks for the question yes on
medicare the program as you know already
covers lab-based tests and
cms over at hhs is exploring the best
way to provide
more testing options to medicare
beneficiaries i want to emphasize that
currently medicare beneficiaries can get
free tests there are 20 000
free testing sites around the country
including at over 10 000 local
pharmacies and other
local convenient locations
hhs is actually providing
50 million free tests free at home tests
to community health centers and medicare
certified
health clinics and as you know
the website is up and running for free
tests for all americans so yes the
answer your question is the
program
already does cover lab tests and i
mentioned the other convenient uh places
for medicare beneficiaries to get tested
and cms is exploring the best way to
provide more testing options to medicare
beneficiaries next question
let's go to victoria knight at kaiser
health
hey thanks kevin um thanks for taking my
question so a couple of questions about
the specifics of the n95 mask
distribution program
so um when are these going masks going
to arrive in the community health
centers
how many of the 400 million from the
strategic national stockpile are going
to community health centers
and then why are these mass not being
shipped directly in the mail with the uh
rapid test kits that are being sent in
the mail via the us postal service
good thank you um so last wednesday a
week ago
we launched the program to to make 400
million and 95
masks available this is the largest
deployment
of ppe personal protective equipment in
u.s history we just determined that the
fastest way to get mass out was through
the channels
that we use for vaccines including
community health centers
and local pharmacies we've already
shipped mass out and we're beginning to
see people pick up
these high quality masks at locations
across the country
they came online at
several locations across the country
through retailers like hyvee walmart and
meyer
last friday so just 48 hours after we
announced the program so the program's
off to a very fast start i think the
decision to use those channels to get
mask out immediately is the right
decision across the next couple of weeks
the program will hit full strength so
americans will be able to pick up free
masks as i said earlier at tens of
thousands
of convenient sites including as you
mentioned community health centers
around the country and local pharmacies
next question
let's go to tamara keith at npr
thank you for taking the question uh at
the top of the briefing you talked about
moving to a place where covid won't
disrupt our lives and it won't be a
crisis um and i i wanted to get you to
tease out that messaging a little bit
more
what does that look like how do we get
there and relatedly um what's the status
of delivery of the antiviral pills from
pfizer um how soon are you expecting to
have those those tens of millions of
pills okay why don't i have dr fauci
start on on the first and then
uh i will talk about the the delivery of
the visor pills dr fauci yeah thank you
very much for that question yes well
people ask that all the time what is an
acceptable situation with regard to sauz
kobe 2 and covet 19 and in this case
omicron that we are willing to live with
in the sense
of not having it disrupt our lives well
first of all the important point to make
is that we are not there right now as dr
wolinski said
when you have over 2 000 deaths 150 000
hospitalizations and you have people who
are now getting infected to the tune of
somewhere around 700 000 a day we're not
there yet
where we want to be
is that sufficient control and control
we mean not eradication like we did with
smallpox that's unreasonable
not necessarily elimination
like we've done with polio and with
measles by mass vaccination campaigns
but a level of control
that does not disrupt us in society does
not dominate our lives do not prevent us
to do the things
that we generally do under normal
existence
that would be a level of infection but
more importantly
concentrating on the severity of disease
hospitalizations and deaths
that fall within the category of what we
generally accept we don't like it but we
accept it with other respiratory viruses
rsv
para flu and even influenza and if the
degree of
immunity in the general community
population either through infection plus
boosting
either vaccine plus boosting
or just vaccine alone those are the
things that will hopefully get us to the
point when we have antivirals to be able
to treat people who are at high risk
that we no longer are in a situation of
threat
threat to our equanimity threat to our
economy the threat to allow us to live a
normal life we believe we can get there
because we have the tools
with vaccines with boosts with masks
with tests and with antivirals that's
what we talk about when we get to the
point where we can quote live with the
virus but as dr wolinski emphasized
that is not where we are at this point
so we still have a way to go
so on pfizer we've purchased
we've purchased 20 million treatment
courses of the pfizer pill and we
accelerated the delivery of the first 10
million
from september to the end of june
we have hundreds of thousands of pills
across
the first quarter of 2022
per month and that moves to moves to
millions in order to complete the 10
million
first half of the 20 million by the end
of june i want to remind everybody that
that is one of five fisa pills one of
five effective treatments that we have
in our nation's medicine cabinet
and that we have more
treatments between the pfizer pills the
merck pill
gsk's monoclonal antibody which is
effective against omicron
astrazeneca's preventive therapy
and rem deserver
we have more available than we've had at
any point in the pandemic and we're
using every tool at our disposal
to keep people safe
next question
all right let's go to alex tin at cbs
all right thanks for taking my question
uh dr swalinski and fauci uh can you
tell us how do we know that johnson and
johnson recipients who are up to date on
their vaccines are protected against
omicron's severe disease and do you
expect we'll see a change to that
regimen for those recipients anytime
soon thanks
dr fauci yeah well i mean if you look at
the data that we're getting on
vaccinations and boosters it is very
very clear i mean obviously we have a
lot more data
in this country on mrna vaccines either
the fisa or the modena
than we do on j and j but there's no
reason to believe given
the parallel protection that we have
seen
with j and j that is boosted
or the mrnas that are boosted
as well as the mix and match which have
been done where you can vaccinate with
one platform and boost with the other we
have found very interestingly that it
works quite well
that they do boost each other
rather well
so in that regard we feel that the
situation that we're seeing with the
mrnas is really quite parallel with the
boosted j and j not the first bose but
the booster j and j
all right
next let's go to cheyenne haslet at abc
thanks guys um for dr fauci i had a
question for you if you could talk a
little bit about this next age group
waiting for
vaccines kids 4 and younger any updates
on
when we will hear from pfizer
on data
i think you talked about that coming the
next month or so and if you could
clarify if this will be for a two dose
or a three dose vaccine which is
expected to be sufficient and then on
paxlovid um
do you think the rollout to patients is
going well or are there things the
government could be doing to make it
easier to obtain
well i'll answer the first question and
then turf to jeff to ask answer the
second
question
with regard to the clinical trials that
are being done in children from six
months to 24 months and from 24 months
through four years
as you probably know the original data
that was done
was determine if the doses that were
given to those children
reached what we call non-inferiority
with a more adult or adolescent
population
and the original data that was put forth
it looked like the dose
and the regimen for the children who
were six months to 24 months worked well
but it turned out that the other dose
namely the other group from 24 months to
four years did not yet reach the level
of non-inferiority so the studies are
continued it looks like it will be a
three dose regimen
i don't think we can predict
when we will see
an eua with that because the company is
still putting the data before
the fda and i certainly don't want to
get ahead of the fda because i'm not
privy to the data and even if i were i
wouldn't want to anticipate what the fda
would do i think we just need to be
patient and know one thing for sure
that that's why the system works because
the fda is very scrupulous in their
ability and in their effort to make sure
that before something gets approved for
people at any age including and
especially children
because of the special vulnerability of
the children
that when these vaccines become
available for children at those age we
can be certain that they will be safe
and that they will be effective bottom
line i can't give you a timetable on
that we just have to wait and see
so on the pills distribution first of
all the fda and nih have provided
guidelines on
which patients should be eligible first
for those pills and then 85 of the pills
have been distributed to the states
the same way we distribute vaccines uh
for them to then uh put the pills in the
most important places within their
states at local
hospitals and health systems and other
caregivers and 15 is going directly to
community health centers around the
country so that we're making sure that
we're reaching those who are
harder to reach in more vulnerable
locations and that our response is fair
and equitable
i think it's important to note that as
soon as we get
monoclonal treatments or pills
we distribute them out to
the states so that they can get to
patients as quickly as possible
next question
let's go to quinn grove at bloomberg
hi there thank you very much uh jeff you
said last week you might have an update
this week on how many
orders have been placed for those uh
tests i'm wondering if you
perhaps have that and for doctors fauci
and wolenski i was hoping twofold number
one do you know why we're seeing the
cases fall as much as we are as quickly
as we are particularly in these big
urban settings is it that we assume
everyone was or many people were more or
less exposed and it's running out of
people to expose to or did people just
clamp down on their behavior
uh and forgive me for adding on last
night tucker carlson's show advised
viewers to stop using
mrna shots entirely
and i wondered if you wanted to respond
to that that show of course has a pretty
significant viewership and that's a
a message that was sent out
last night thank you okay josh i think
that was three questions let me let me
go first and
as we said uh last week we will have an
initial
uh report on orders by the end of this
week uh so that will be coming we've
seen strong demand um and the website
has worked very well taking in orders
quickly and efficiently
importantly you know already tens of
millions of tests have gone out the door
and are arriving and many have arrived
at people's mailboxes and
and doors so uh we look forward to
getting more and more americans free
tests directly at their doorstep in the
days and weeks
ahead um dr wolinski do you want to take
the second question on the
steepness of the decline and then dr
fauci if you want to make any comments
on mrna vaccines
happy too thanks josh um so you know the
the shape of the increase the slope of
the increase and the steepness of
decline is what has been mirrored in
other countries as well south africa and
uk have seen similar trends um i think
it's a combination of what you've been
what you commented on first that people
are behaving differently in the context
of omicron many are you know
masking up many are doing more
distancing than they had before in the
wow we're in the middle of this surge i
also think that there's a large
component of people who are vaccinated
people who are getting boosted and some
who are who have been previously
infected now many who have been
previously infected now either with
omicron itself or with prior variants
where would they have some enduring
protection um maybe if i could just
comment on the mrna vaccine and just say
last week cdc put out data that
demonstrated that if you are boosted you
are 68 times less likely to die than if
you are unvaccinated our hospitals are
full of people who have not been
vaccinated and i would encourage people
to go get vaccinated i'll see if dr
fauci has anything to add
yeah i think the data speaks for
themselves we we make recommendations
based on the scientific data and the
observations
particularly those that dr walensky has
just
mentioned uh the overwhelming proportion
of people in this country who are
vaccinated have gotten mrna vaccinations
either the moderna or the pfizer and if
you look at the data you can't walk away
from the facts and the facts are
stunningly obvious
when you look at the hospitalization and
deaths among unvaccinated versus
vaccinated versus vaccinated and boosted
so there really isn't much to say about
that except that the facts speak for
themselves
kevin next question
let's go to david lynn at politico
hi thanks for taking my question
um senators patty murray and richard
burr yesterday released draft
legislation calling for the cdc director
job to be subject to senate confirmation
does the bed administration support this
proposal and directly director wallinski
do you believe that this will strengthen
accountability during future public
health responses or do you think that
the idea let me let me take this first
so so first of all i want to say we look
forward to
reviewing the bill and appreciate the
senator's focus on pandemic preparedness
and making sure that we never ever face
a pandemic of this magnitude
again um you know i think that we'll
leave it to congress to sort through
uh the the cdc
director
um status of confirmation
uh and overall we look forward to you
know engaging with the with the senate
uh on the on as the bill comes together
doctor willis you have anything to add
there no i i don't have much to add i
just will um echo the gratitude and say
right now my focus um is on i will
certainly review the bill um but also
focusing on
you know the pandemic that we have on
our hands right now
kevin
all right
last question let's go to zeke miller
um thanks again for doing this um i just
wanted to follow up on dr faggy's
comments in response to tam's question
um regarding the
living with with covid um is it your
sense uh doctors that this is the last
disruptive surge
of of coping 19 given all of the tools
you know vaccines boosters
uh antibodies and the like you know is
there is there a light at the end of the
tunnel that you see now
and what metrics are you looking for uh
for to start
you know giving people hope to you know
book travel and you know
take off masks and return to normal
normal lives of normalcy
dr fauci
yeah well zeke there's uh we tend to
explain it in the terms of
a best-case scenario and a worst-case
scenario we all are hoping for and i
believe
we likely would get more towards the
best than a worst case scenario but we
don't know
you've got to be prepared for the worst
but anticipate and look at the data as
it's evolving and what the best case
scenario and it really relates just to
very briefly reiterate what i said
before
where if you get enough protection from
either infection plus boost
or infection plus boost again or
vaccination with boosting hopefully
because we know how important boosting
is that you will get a level of
protection in the community that even if
you get another variant that you will
not see a surge associated with that
variant but you'll have enough
background immunity to protect against
it
the level that we want to so-called
accept living with it is what i
mentioned in answer to a previous
question we want to make it low enough
so that it doesn't disrupt our
capability to function in society in a
relatively normal way
we do that with other respiratory
viruses we know that we get rsv
particularly against vulnerable the
elderly and children we get para
influenza we get influenza these are
important we try our best to contain
them
but they don't disrupt us
with regard to challenging our hospital
system with regard to challenging the
entire healthcare delivery system
that's where we want to be and i believe
that we will get there hopefully sooner
rather than later
but as i say that i say we still will
always be prepared
for the possibility that there may be a
variant that will make that timetable
turn around and so that's the reason why
we're doing all of the things that we're
doing including my presentation a little
bit ago
about a pan coronavirus vaccine thank
you yeah i would just add to what dr
falchi said you know
it's stark contrast to where we were a
year ago we now have the tools
to protect ourselves our communities our
schools and our businesses the vaccines
the boosters
the tests
the mass the treatment
that makes this response so different in
our situation in our country so
different than it was a year ago and
going forward as dr fauci said we'll
continue
to have those tools and we'll continue
to innovate to ensure that we protect
people
and we can begin to be on our path to
managing this virus so that it's no
longer a crisis but something that we
protect against and treat
thank you for today's briefing look
forward to the next one
you